[Music]
[Music]
you
hey guys we're playing call of duty
black ops 3 zombies Chronicles I'm Cali
I'm joined by Rob handler II hi
we got Jason from Treyarch yelling and a
joke Activision playing and off cam we
have jake playing so tell us a little
bit about zombies chronicles Before we
jump into it
sure yeah it's um I suppose the best the
best way to describe would be eight
remastered Maps going back from world
war all the way through to black ops 2
some classics passage in there yeah but
kind of brought up-to-date with it with
the power of the new console so ps4 a
lot of the ideas we had early on for
kind of zombie maps you can only really
realize it with the kind of the new kind
of power so we did our best back in the
day but with the power of the new
consoles you can really kind of make the
thriller and horror stuff come to life
yeah alright let's jump in let's play
ready together so we're playing on 20
gopher verrückt fantastic oh boy I heard
yeah I'm nervous no pressure guys
okay all right oh it's been so long oh
here we go yeah ready
the maps you gotta know the maps I care
about this one as well I'm knowing well
this is something we found out which was
you know before doing this map back we
were talking about you know what we
should do we found out that a lot the
people joined in zomb is it let's say
black ops 2 and so I hadn't experienced
some of the World War Maps or the black
sheer map so but some of the old-timers
will be like I remember this one but a
lot of people be first time they'd
experience them yeah the the one we I
kept talking about yeah
kino der toten yep that one was that was
water war right it was it was well it
was it was really interesting so so yes
and no so oh um we actually planned Kino
but what was called DLC for the time for
world at war but we never see released
it and so it kind of got folded in later
on it was it was Kino there was a coast
which got turned into call of the dead
mmm and and then there was a Paris map
that we've got turned into moon which is
also in zombie chronicles so every
little bit that we kind of developed at
the studio gets moved and changed and
ultimately finds its way out to the
community hitting the gobble gums
already nice there we go
so those have been added right and yes
they've united yes so there's a whole
new set of systems we put in black ops 3
which is just happy for the gobblegum
system right and again that's a
take-it-or-leave-it kind of option so
some people say ah I'm I'm the og I
don't play with gobblegum sure and you
don't have to write you don't write I
don't use that machine and if you do
there's now tons and tons of gobble gums
we have not only one who can change the
gameplay but also get this whimsical
class which is kind of fun and kind of
have things like the zombies flying into
the air or strange colors of you know
the fun stuff and and then the maps that
didn't have perks in we've added the the
wonderful machine which brings different
kind of perks to you as well as as well
as early maps we we didn't really have
the vast majority of our permission so
did you have to do like a lot of like
remodeling for any
any of the weapons or now weapons
because these are all from blackops
obviously well it interesting of yeah
all of it because like weapons is a
great one there's obvious all the black
ops three weapons and they can
automatically come in yeah a lot of
these maps have special weapons that are
considered parent favorites and but you
can't really use the assets that you had
from before so everything had to be
built scrapped so one of the
considerations is you know which weapons
do we want to bring over to this San
Juans where people like yeah I love that
weapon and it's kind of synonymous with
this maps or like okay let's put that
one in but we can do every single one so
that was actually one of those tough
decisions which is like okay which ones
are we going to realize which ones we're
going to put it but in terms of the giro
and again all absolutely brand-new
because we had to the package we use to
make the levels called radian and it's
changed so much that we here Oh
everyone's yeah well I go down yeah I'm
talking as you guys are dying so we had
to build the whole thing from scratch on
all the models and you know we started
off kind of saying okay we'll just do a
few of the models but what you realized
very quickly is all the models that
aren't up to date just stand out like a
sore thumb
so we said I'll just do the whole thing
so it's pretty much bill from scratch
and then audio you know obviously
probably noticing the lighting but right
lighting is absolutely from scratch
again
but audio everything essentially had to
be remastered and resampled at a high
rate and so as you're walking along
you'll have like step triggers you'll
hear glass breaking of your feet or you
bump into something you'll hear those
sounds that's good you have more
channels now on the new hardware so you
can really build that thrill I kinda
horror vibes a lot of that is sounded
Lighting's how we kind of create tension
absolutely yeah we played um probably
about thirty minutes this morning Jake
and I and we noticed that like the
Dakotan map the dogs seemed there audios
can be completely different it's so
great they had like a hyena life in it I
don't know what you'd call it like a
screech it was it was actually really
much scarier I feel yeah they did they
remastered everything and then we mix
mostly because in the past again you
have a certain number channels a certain
amount of sample rate you could do the
most of you have you can kind of build
on that creepiness factor you have more
things kind of lurking or being lower in
there kind of mix and you know people
experiencing this on headphones when
they first start playing it I would
highly recommend a surround sound set up
if you really get the true experience
goods
it's it's fantastic enough here those
dogs come in from behind oh yeah oh yeah
yeah turn the lights off when you play
this man oh god I am dead are you guys
doing we're a team going we're doing
okay looking for the power since I can't
remember anything
I remember just before the stream you
said I'm gonna be playing and also doing
the talking and I could to see you just
a bazillion oh no I'm gonna figure it
out then I'm gonna start talking I swear
um I don't remember this math as well
yeah nice yeah
um did they all have like the teleport
system in like lectric fences was that a
standard they had the electric trap uh
we didn't have the teleport at this
point teleport was introduced in derice
okay reset my daddy told me especially
now I said it I was actually Germany and
I reason I kept okay saying Therese sure
James took me aside and said you are
saying this wrong so it's going to be
Theresa but uh but we remade that for
the Giant
so the Giants is remaking three so
that's when we introduced the teleporter
pack-a-punch machine motor bombs all
that cocaine whoo monkeys off that
monkeys you gotta love monkeys amount of
times I've been screaming throw a monkey
yeah Oh God yeah we're doing fine we're
great
there's two things I think for any kind
of successful game monkeys and fire
you've got those two things in the game
monkeys in fire my maker right is that
the idea bonfires it makes a lot of a
cash uh what the fire what's so great
about fire oh just this visual element
oh just you know you'll see like around
the place but a bit of fire in there but
a monkey in there you got winning forms
BAM yeah and he put symbols on him and
dynamite do
though the showers of blood watch after
showers of blood yeah yeah boy yeah
we're fine high school huh okay oh my
god oh my god
no no dude so then if there wasn't the
teleporter and this one was there the an
upgrade box or anything
hey you have the magic box how do you
have that oh and then you have you have
now the Wonder fizz in there which means
you can get access to all your different
purple
gotcha oh god I'm gonna die I'm so gonna
die right now
that won't happen I don't know if you
watching the stream can see this but I'm
just looking at a bunch of Fonuts as if
these guys just kind of street barrier
I'm gonna do it
um yeah when I wasn't playing I was
listening to my brother play so one of
the main things I remember is like music
and sound effects oh yeah please
I just always walked how creepy it was
oh god it's the zombie screech oh yeah
screen I mean I would go to sleep after
pills at 3:00 a.m. with that just in my
brain I never miss a yeah you sleep all
night
it's a bit scary yeah it's over
Oh coming you dick you're doing well
okay I have a lot of so in this one -
you were split up right yeah that was a
new it was a new idea at the time which
was the idea of changing things up like
not always giving a predictable flow
yeah
and that's something that we've done
through zombies all the way another
planets and DHEC power which is alright
now we're on gotcha
we did I know I need more money - oh my
god well I got a head shots of something
where is a juggernaut this one um good
question hahaha hey Ana who can remember
what do you want you want Sami team Oh
God
anymore oh my god revive me I have a
ready good night
should I get you guys kick you know
we're gonna open you can get through the
door I think now sweet turn on the power
what's that two down two to go yeah this
is going great this is a great warm-up
at maximum ultra platinum am alone so
how do I get there you get up there you
go you guys hang in there yeah I'm doing
my best
oh there are you guys alright Hey hi how
are you thanks
what's new for all the help I really
appreciate I'm out of juice any more
emails dialog so find us - yeah we're
juice yeah the the 1.0 characters were
very uh very verbose hey
breaking the fourth wall of his bed
absolutely yeah I was always worried I
was like my parents left clearly there's
a lot of style oh there's a lot of
screaming in the office when we played
scared screaming or frustrated screaming
or both uh you can't really detect ready
with the gargling and the blood and
everything it's one of the things
there's also probably a lot of screaming
like at your teammate first yeah you
over what are you doing
why what happened why don't you throw
that monkey I love you Oh God
I love these daily Maps yeah
deliberately down TIF again slow down
like we deliberately do something Oh
makes frustrating mode
sure okay right it's new it's always
those like um but the moonlight over
with me you know people can get it and
take off and just leave someone behind
you make that call right yeah yeah the
same thing was with the Dragon when we
you know did the dark frozen the
blackest cream so these maps really kind
of slide a lot of those principles that
we kept on going
Oh give that money you have that minigun
when you cover hurry up um yeah or just
the map design - right look with key
things you're toting whoever just saw
like penis yeah I just have that
ingrained in my brain so like certain
paths that you decide to take and then
there's that stairway quicker just
forget about that like a couple zombies
can be coming up and then we do exits
gone we do some fun stuff which people
really shouldn't notice but I'll let you
look behind the curtain little bit well
do think of lighting or other or the
structure of a corridor that means
subliminally we know you're gonna run
left rather than right so for instance
if we use a warm core like an orange and
then put the other corridor to look blue
most people don't orange code oh wow so
what we can do is we can subliminally
get you to kind of go the way we want to
make you go I games we're getting yeah
yeah so there's that these principles
are really well understood and you can
make decisions in your map building but
that means that most the time we know
where you're going to go okay
okay time and then their lives like the
a way of like facilitating excitement
right like you think this is gonna be a
right hallway yeah then it's a brick
wall yeah your heart skips a beat
exactly yeah that's cool
we talked a little bit about like kind
of the people who join who join it on
zombies like black ops 2 yeah what was
the process like for choosing which Maps
I'm sure any heart is architect we sat
down with the intention of making four
maps for zombie chronicles oh really
just formats and the process was just
incredibly hard we're sitting there and
said well we got to put this one in we
got to put that one in and then we got
to the point where I forget it let's
just put all like so we did eight and
then there's still conversations about
what we could go even further you know
probably do 12 and I was like come on
guys this is done
I'm sure the community would have loved
it but it was it was literally reaching
the end of how much we could do in the
amount of time to do it but it was very
difficult even with the eight it was
still very difficult Pickers but what we
felt was these ones were it gave a nice
variety of odd maps and easier maps you
know one that people might raise their
eyebrows out was a nest for example yeah
totem by a lot of hardcore guys
standards they would say that's a very
easy map a nice straightforward map but
it's a map that if you don't play
zombies before it's a lot more
approachable and so we thought it was
essential to put it in there absolutely
the hardcore guys have all been trained
on these little mad crazy ones now right
but we also want to pack that if you're
new to zombies or you've seen your
friends playing it it's just a little
bit of a kind of a smoother curve to
come in and so so that's why map by
batter in there but then it goes always
the more complicated thing like origins
or moon where the Easter Egg started to
get quite complex and the mechanics were
particular lushing as well so hopefully
this kind of combination of easier maps
of people is going to come into and then
hard amount so they kind of die hard
guys are playing it but what ten years
there yeah my gosh the community is
really yeah it's incredible they're
amazing and I get the opportunity opt
into going to meet up with everyone and
we did it a cod XP yeah ever other
youtubers gonna come down Shore and
those guys just
absolutely fantastic because they think
they know it as well as any my particle
guys but if not a little bit more so
just talking for fun they're just yeah
there are always like one step ahead of
you as far as like uh we'll go that far
what what I mean is I jump to be a
little bit ahead of that as far as like
Easter eggs right like I just feel like
that's the stuff that is mind-blowing me
where everyone oh yeah is able to figure
out like you know sometimes there isn't
even a prompt right up and it'll it'll
do something like you guys like just
litter that stuff we'll do like
backwoods sounds no finery and then what
we will do
images hidden in Texas I don't mind him
so did you hide anything in zombies
chronicles on yes I love that line
that's as far as you gonna get with that
questioning yeah so yeah I mean it's
it's incredible I started on a point
cycle them you know we do different
encryption systems no just I just wanna
find out like how far would the
community go and the answer is really
fun decrypted them all and found all the
messages but I ain't no I spoke about
some secrets
is there like a a method that like these
guys are using as far as like
discovering then like is there like okay
first we're gonna just mash I like to
activate button around every corner
yeah is there any like like they do they
will they do that they also do states of
mining where they pick it up like if you
see if you go to all the files out there
and even though I I you know I'm
sickened by that action I also kind of
congratulate it there's real dedication
and tell you about the amount of passion
immune to the fat little take up in a
proc and as such actual Easter eggs in
assuming that they'll take the whole
thing apart and see everything that we
put in them but the way they solve it
well not just the sheer number of people
playing in the thread saying this yeah
we're we're know they're in role in the
radio subreddit those following along in
the YouTube videos you know whatever a
map pack comes out you're seeing that
now is not because so many people
playing there's so many people screaming
that collectively they're the biggest
knowledge base it could possibly put out
it you know it's incredible
it's funny to think that like like as
far as Easter eggs go you knocks on down
great not to be in this style of game
right worth wave-based and it's just
like - yeah like five times a look in
this corner here that's when you start
kiting one lobby yeah and oh my god I'm
down now I tried to talk and I feel
every trick every time I try to say
something really I don't know
I'm not holding a troll easy okay yeah
it's it's you know that's that's the
reason why it's so much fun right
because it's it's a game mode where you
think you don't have any time and you
don't but it forces the players to be
resourceful to going to give himself the
space to find this stuff yeah like my
brother and I would seriously just like
height one mm hey guys like near crawler
I was yeah I was mention this in an
interview recently which is we haven't
variable which would stop training
really yeah it's a weird a variable
which was spread which meant that Rob
Zombie's all following in the line who's
been the variable of everyone will start
spreading out and then you can't
actually we have like a hardcore Espinal
up in the Pacific and when we turned it
up they couldn't finish any the maps
anymore no really they couldn't get any
high rounds and that makes sense because
like we mean as far as like how we would
play yeah you get like um a high fire
rate weapon and maybe like your shotgun
a rape and then you would just you would
have to corner yeah line them up and
then just mode hell yeah those lines and
that's when I was telling you the story
when I was playing college my buddy and
we wait til 3:00 a.m. and
thought we could pick it up in the
morning before school perk yeah okay you
ready
I'm boss yeah yeah and that's all about
getting that rhythm of like Yeley like
hosing down zombie lines yeah it's
insertion complete the training
technique only really came into play a
little bit later in the world warmer
when they first started I should
probably back up for me when we first
started the tactic to playing zombies
would find a good corner and stay there
you know it was only later they
discovered oh we can train people round
and you could start using the
environment so with people first I
playing it they were more just terrified
into the corner so work and then and
then of course yeah you're now you
refraining creating paths and routes
yeah and then the funniest is what
always happens when I was playing like a
day was like you would be like there's
extra ammo
and it's there it's behind three zombies
and you know no you know this is bad
they're doing like don't Adam don't do
it you think I gotta get it and I've
done Adam always now
you guys a holding you're looking at
luxury okay it's pretty good rounds well
I'm just gonna stop trying to speak I
think oh great I'll interview you yeah
we uh we got to play keno after this oh
yeah yeah we did again yeah jaqen
airplanes mornings were just like oh
yeah yeah like oh yeah these crawler
gas-filled zombies that worse for coming
now got oh oh these maps are pretty up I
like oh there you go
yeah it's all on you but let's be dead
today I'm just I'm just trying to see
the next map so we can do it yeah I'm
just trying to speed it up you never
turn right we really got to see more
maps than just this one so okay it's
really my strategy that's the excuses of
professional hey what's Roswell guys
Junior that's good see this is a really
nice way of looking at how who was
talking and it was not Jake um cool yeah
yeah
talking and playing is so hard
especially this yeah
usually is just me screaming for 20
straight minutes can't really do that on
the stream though so how many maps again
mate 8 9 maps 8 maps remastered already
messed it from the ground up every every
part of it and gobble gums in their
weapon build kits on the black ops 3
weapons you got there as I said the
wonderful is put in so that if your
level didn't have folks before it does
now
all new mastered sound models geo the AI
itself got updated as well it's it's
interesting like I I don't like the idea
of remaster and I we still talk about
remaster this and be most of that but I
was really about okay how do we
reimagine this so how do we take what
they're kind of gameplay though it was
classic before and reimagine because I'm
not interested in remasters I'm
interested in reimagining the experience
get the vibe of what we did but using
the new tools and techniques that we
know have easily surely have tough
balance preserving like yeah yeah
because you play you're playing with the
stuff you know yeah especially when
you're like like this map I mean we've
all mentioned like oh the memories on
this map you don't want to mess with
somebody's like nostalgia of it should
also want to provide them with something
that's um
like you said a reimagining a fresh take
yeah it's totally deviating from what
you remember and you got the design team
there so as the designers kind of
playing with this stuff you'll say okay
so now we have three hits rather than
two hits on the zombies so now you
notice that yeah so then they'll say
okay so that makes it easier this way
and then we're going to add this element
to make it hot so they have to rebalance
everything but keep the spirit the same
and and that's really kind of tricky and
they work very hard to do that the whole
team worked incredibly hard to make this
whole project we honest it was a it was
always passion projects you know don't
really start doing work you know we do
the games and we love the games we do
there's also a job component to what
you're doing work yeah this one was your
passion from the team like I've never
seen it before I was like we got to do
this go do that and then I had pages and
pages of suggestions from the team of
like look for this Easter alien
he's grabbing actually my hard job cuz I
seem to say no let's not do some of them
um just flood some splinters suggest get
a crush couple dreams yeah bossy every
so often here that's the downside of
being a dresser yeah yeah
are there any easter eggs that I don't
know I know there is that over arcing
narrative right yes that eventually was
like implemented is there anything um
Papa I can answer you can take you a
question I'm gonna turn it don't worry
right right yeah uh any Easter eggs that
call to like any other of the zombies
that were whipped black ops three four
as far as Maps or characters or um I'm
glad you asked for that question I could
avoid it completely alright so we
released a when we announced zombie
chronicles we we also revealed the full
zombie timeline right is a bit kind of
poster image which talked about all the
different crews there's there's there's
primarily three different groups you're
playing the one point is it's gonna call
that I won't get too much into the the
timeline but and there was different
ones like the premise group the one
point owes as the transit group is it as
they called and there was certainly
there's certain things we kind of got in
there but it was also it's also
important to kind of preserve at what
point in the story chronicles represent
that's probably the most roundabout
answer I've ever given no actually I I
got I got a lot of okay the timeline is
actually a good segue because if you're
joining us we have a giveaway that's and
one of the things included in the
giveaway is a poster with the timeline
um so if you go on GameSpot's twitter we
have
Twitter put on a tweet with the giveaway
you follow GameSpot retweet for a chance
to win and we'll pick today can I enter
that uh I'm gonna hazard a guess yeah
thanks for that
I saw you can be perched me well you get
to watch us you get to light us is
entertaining masterful gameplay this is
worth the trip wasn't Cisco and that
giveaway for watching his us only
unfortunately we apologize and I'm gonna
stop talking right now because oh here
we go
nice Oh No yes headshot help wait don't
go yet
and any headshot to go through got the
headshot challenge going on at a moment
also hello alright oh God
we have these oh man I'm actually the og
Kohli
oh no I'm doing it oh describe those
again so there's like a I think it's
four stage challenge and in each stage
we're unlocking gamer cards for the
community already hit certain numbers
and those those are done by Yoji
Shinkawa who's the artist for Metal Gear
you know before you know there's there
kind of ink rushed in a style and he
basically depicted each one of our four
main characters and so as the community
hits those headshot counts
they'll unlock those Monica
these rooms or so like I just this looks
great but I also want to just like see
what's different I want to like go back
and look at the original I know you guys
did okay thing is your memories HD I
don't know if you like nature oh
absolutely I think back to like in my
8-bit games back in the day it's all
wonderful 1080p quality of my mind yeah
it's amazing kind of seeing it because
York York you fill in the details you
know you go back and look at the
original you like wow I don't remember
it looking like that I need a mystery
box like whoa oh my god this is it I'd
be like I told you this is the worst
spot oh I just got bottlenecks so bad
um well anyway well I'm down uh if
you're just joining us for playing at
Holiday like okay zombies Chronicles
eight remastered classics off these maps
again we have a giveaway um with codes
posters t-shirts and even a mini-fridge
so if you're interested in any fridge
yes if you're interested in that
followed being shot on Twitter and
retweet our tweet about this just
checking on Twitter um at game spot and
uh you'll pick winners at the end of day
there was many pictures are very
collectible now because there's only a
limited run of them okay we announced it
at a Comic Con when we won we announced
black ops 3 and I've put one on stage
and showed it and I think from the mum
we I showed it
I think we didn't like somebody three
hours or a handful of hours they were
all sold they're all gone really so yeah
the mini-fridge is a essential bit for
every fan mm-hmm hey uh hot ticket item
mm-hmm okay I did not get the gun I want
will keep your sodas cold obviously soft
drinks oh yeah yeah good enough it Oh
so try my turn I'm all old school I got
uh we got an m16 here an mp40 oh here we
go oh my god
you tell me yeah we have probably engine
40 you would have happened right so was
that like a complete remodeling or did
you like pull assets at all and like
touched it up so we're quite lucky
because for the campaign which we did so
for black ops 3 we did a flashback level
which actually went back to have like
things like Nazi Germany until we have
the FP forces which is you can get away
that is quite nice yeah yeah oh this
room now I know what I'm taking I'm
taking them to hell with me so I'm just
shooting what I can't see well I'm here
oh god so much just hit these turrets as
you're running around yeah yes my audio
here I don't remember this so much
already and tak okay they don't know yet
though right I don't think I mean dared
nobody like well they scare you a little
bit and then they come too low later I
think you're about to find out
come on I need a real weapon yes yeah
here's that hyenas freaked out somewhat
earlier I love it cuz you guys asked oh
I love it I love that life so much I'll
hop in a second okay fine run away
god I love dogs like the most part you
can like play it safe and be okay but
you can easily like oh yeah slip if
you're well paying attention I know
somebody's enemies a design mystical
treasure on you to connect mistakes
rather I'll show you right oh oh yeah
exactly you like that you can like run
away from them yet again today I feel -
anything about zombies right the idea
there just kind of walk toward lose it
they'll win because will change your
attention focuses on how they get you
I'm great
the level of folks and conservationists
papers incredible I know
buddies as I was saying like how you can
like slip I was like slipping I know
like we're dogs on here don't even try
to talk to David rhew uh max am no you
guys later I love the gaba the like
lines and the sound effect it is so
iconic to me like you get hmm Jake says
the telephone jake has been doing Jason
work really putting in the work yeah
he's probably grinding his teeth like
work for a dude oh here they come
Oh God
these zombies have hey you got green
ones
hey the Nova crawlers no oh my god let's
go hair real piggy oh oh I'm not doing
that your friends have left you behind
I can avert Lee left them I feel like oh
oh and this is it this is what the end
looks like this basically
Elias yeah it's not wrong that's right
back my boy the UH the perks in this one
pack a punch
see I don't remember if it's a charter
nut a quick revive that was one you
always say for laughs laughing quickly
uh do not screw your friend
gotta get the tiger not yeah oh why do
you make a big deal out of that I was
just your youngest big hey hey don't
want to die again
well that's cool cuz I'm gonna get the
Thunder waffle whatever it's called
right Thunder no no don't eat to me oh
yes Oh No
oh I'm down oh oh oh I'm trying
I'll do it bad things are about to
happen this hey wha no those round nine
just everybody take a deep breath
twelve twelve to beat you going fine
there's no time for breathing nobody's
crying everything's great
you are really stressed out
I am super HD visuals old-timey feelings
so you can you can upgrade each gun once
or you can even do a couple more times
right yeah you can yeah you can pack
punches watch it twice and then you have
you know special abilities that you can
also - you keep on ready in case we
don't get there yeah do you have the
same hey yeah I don't know it could
happen could have it won't yeah is it
the same kind of like I remember being
like a kind of Chrome yes you have a
picture you say we have different and so
we have different penguin skin to get
weapons and that's uh they're changing
all these masks
but yeah that's a note people remember
they can ignore everyone with they're
gonna inlay and so forth like the
grooves yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah there's four behind me yep yep
this is going Greek
bumpkin I got it I got it good now come
revive me step on it they're not all
right
juggernaut yeah Jesus
yeah you're on three years what we're
just trying to Superboy we're just I
yeah
Jake is off camber just mumbling like
Jake's like oh my teleporter guys guys
stop dying just like stop well should we
go let's go yeah wait he's Jake's holy
right yeah and then yeah that's the
really do need Mike
okay thanks Jake uh hey hold on
was it our clown happens in a moment of
cunning did you just shout one punch
from Star Wars that did you see the
stuff was cool I just need to chewy at
the front man are you getting pepper
you've just discovered I'm a major
source man nothing great all right well
thank God
lifti Jakes I'm really glad that we
asked Jake to play yeah I got a feeling
Jake had this all planned once again you
guys are looking for another map change
the show up another one of the master go
yeah that's right we intentionally did
that okay yeah weird this is all part of
our oh okay yeah oh yeah what I can yeah
I'm just spectating you now rocket
launcher why you this is the future edge
we just let him play it we just I think
we should have just let you play this'll
uh-huh is the what rock monter even good
we always like me I never used the
sniper rifle or rocket launcher I could
never like hurt a case for it ah it's uh
yeah definitely
you got good distance pretty good whoo
yeah all right well yeah second look
another one check out another map how
convenient everyone
um Wow we're gonna go for why I'm down
for whatever but while we're on the
screen if you're joining us we're
checking out more maps we've done kino
der toten and it's something else that's
Brookes little and we're checking out
more maps from black ops 3 zombies
chronicles while we wait what's
everybody's favorite map I can't say ok
probably fair yeah never mind you guys
inside
I mean it's it's kina fur for me yeah
only ok what was it
SSI attention let's dig is that one
that's been added yeah yeah let's do a
pension ol ascension um yeah it's we
just picked one and just try to like
perfect it right and I think we got to
wave 45 maybe and that was about it but
we just had to like play with that same
map anytime we changed it up we'd be
like what's this again well yeah
essentially fun one it's it's it's
probably one that for people who can't
play the original probably has one of
the most distinctive kind of makeovers
in terms of the amount stuff that's now
in it oh great the lighting of it
and let's say you kept a lot of the same
like kind of the artwork at least from
the style oh yeah yeah yeah so this is
one of the movie planes like JFK and no
that was that was five that was uh like
ups Warren because we did the Pentagon
level in the campaign that's the one
that we took that that would send it to
fives here like Castro and JFK perfect
all that fun stuff that was the big
fella is it beginning the only ones
where we're kind of playing with
celebrity casting for novelty nobody
cast never I I don't think I've ever
played oh yeah all right well this is
gonna push is about ladies and gentlemen
you rent to see a very from a section of
game right yeah all right
I was kidding Karia forgetting the
darker sort of hip Joe single-handedly
Joe yeah there you go
there's no there's also nothing like
dying like wave three I will just land
elated really most embarrassing things
like goodbye
I get kill them I that's what I was just
thinking so what's the path here yeah
what's our goal now that we have time to
kind of relax yeah yeah I'm so relaxed
right now well you're less relaxed we're
more relaxed than you are later yeah so
yeah what are we with her mo here you go
up these stairs where's the power right
good always powered there's always power
what would you recommend Joe what's not
ready
what I was like almost like a oh yeah
but like uh yeah I got like a city burn
less saturated uh uh very Thomas right
yeah and so it's very saturated to
certain power on and then all the kind
of follicle so that was one of the kind
of Phoenix we did when we originally did
it okay but now you kind of have post
effect engine and so forth it really
have fun with it you're liking the
course you should see it when you switch
the power sealed it for this program we
will get there you guys already will do
it so is there a way I just imagine it
has to be true but like as far as these
earlier ones like keno for instance um
is there a type of like algorithm or
formula to like putting like an it's to
kill or anything like behind a certain
amount of of zombies during like a wave
verson like that there isn't it's it's
very interesting so one thing we found
with zombies was that we had to be
careful not to be too plug because the
system that kind of runs it on wrong map
is pretty much identical to the nectar
if you start building in conditions they
start to break apart and not work as
well so the actual kind of formula that
sits underneath all the maps is
essentially the same there's a couple of
little tweaks it's more to do with flow
and spawn control but on the most part
they're zombies in the drops also the
transfer is all a convictable
system
we could make it unpredictable but you
said - all right part of the fun is
getting into that rhythm you know when
you say about I'm playing it I
understand understand it because you can
start to pick that River right we could
have it randomize it we just met
everybody else but there's that kind of
reward the hard part which isn't playing
over and over again we can start to
understand what's happened if we were
trying to put connect Club missing those
people start detecting it realizing what
happened
it just happens to me it happens to be
this and we call it like not zombie God
looks like it's like luring us into
death very important thing about zombies
is when you die you should be blaming
yourself not the game yeah yeah and that
was a very important thing about the
zombie experience which was when people
died in games it's very often to say oh
the girl you know I did that to me did
this to me or you know when you really
want more more maps to show up yes but
this is like most people in the guy in
zombies because they realize that they
made a mistake right the zombies is
moving at the same speed all the stuff
is exactly the same and it was a good
choice on the players part rather than
the game just gained me you just did
something that it shouldn't have you
know mm-hmm right there's always a
post-mortem and it's like yeah yeah a
lot of times it then leads into an
argument yes for me yeah what were you
doing
not what we were
oh wow look good love it I just that
tension I just shake you guys you know
my god
here we go yes do it flip it on flip it
there we go now we're having fun oh my
god
I went too close to the very G idiot
they came from behind
hey game from its spot great this way so
is it me
oh yeah my dude okay good enough push
once someone was blocking me and that's
fight so whoever I was that your fault
hmm whatever I'm kidding
anyways but you could tell I was so
focused on killing what's next not a
good one
what okay we played whatever the harsh
on that one is that again
I like these the Swan no no it's [ __ ] a
new one okay shangri-la is the jungle in
an unknown location oh boy whoa
I think maybe we'll survive this
hey I need this one's a hard one I got a
hay which I'm that's good yeah looks
like it oh yes admire how pretty it is
this is gonna have my dog William as we
die um well which game was this for uh
Shang was black ops 1 wrong now up
you've another chance could be saying
really putting you on the spot yeah no
yeah tournament birthing was alright
but this is going to one of those maps
where back in the day you can only do so
much with the
the overdraw the alpha you know so the
foliage had to be limited in certain
ways draw distances had to be limited
and so kind of coming back to it now we
can cram it full of foliage have a
longer drivers push the fog back so you
get a little bit more detail a sense of
scale and you're able to predict wavers
are these
they're here whatever the monkeys oh
wait what now with HD symbol yeah the
power of the PlayStation 4 being put the
Tesla sounds really good know some of
the very nice gone then via does the
Gong do anything does it
blur it's got something yeah Gong Gong
that was an accident well I was just so
busy gone I have a feeling the post
mortem will be about why why did you
decide yeah yeah hey guys we should have
hit the zombies more in the god bless so
that Gong is dead you'll hit a home just
for next time love you guys
yeah this one this map ramps up pretty
pretty sharp
yeah lighting looks for the gray yeah
they all different oh yeah so this is
slow
this is slower in the swampy area Oh
guys don't go in there
we're going there and save me dang oh my
god I'm out of ammo II I mean I need a
gun
please help me welcome it's nice to
experience that oh I'm so many people
right where it's like oh let's cut
through here I was a little like a
electric fences replaced by wooden you
have different date doors Travis and
traps yeah I mean these ones up after
you rather than the other traps that all
but the other different punji sticks can
I go I know nice thank you
hmm I'm just mailing Wow look I can look
that oh that's really pretty
[ __ ] me diving hey oh so pretty oh come
on guys I'm at a mo I have not been
paying attention Ron okay egg let me see
any weapons around here um oh it's
really slow in here you were right oh
geez
haha again I'm going underground
well oh I know
but you got let me be envious it yeah
would you get
our data it's I'm heading down
you guys played this on earth or is this
it this is my first time playing this
one oh nice I haven't played this one oh
wow either but I saw a lightning bolt II
look at arrow so I figured that's good I
should follow it it's the more of them
in there they just lie to you hahaha
something mess with me yeah if I do that
next time it's just because of you love
this place
cool yeah just pointing this way for
power just kidding lots of zombies then
I'll make healthy made it into the game
you free to make fun of me
I really need some money
I
we'll just like the you this is the
spawn of the original like Nazi Zombies
the idea that like lizard lizard' a
single person who just like had this
idea like it was a who's gonna
collection guys it was uh so it was
birth in World at War and world at war
was no challenging project to do it air
is a very big project but we introduced
W I did which was flamethrower and so as
such we then did animation because
people on fire which was this OH
and that's that's what became the basis
of the Azam B and then where that was
like this is kind of yeah absolutely
kind of put that in and it kind of
showed a couple of the guys and then the
Paris apartment said ah well we could
make you a you know a zombie head and
stick it I want to be aa the characters
only and then the sound Department got
involved at all we can make some sounds
and do that and it just kind of grew
from there
can I start building a building and then
the the point that was very interesting
was loads of people are playing through
their lunch breaks and after hours
even after through very full days and
doing all that works with harness is
amazing and then we had this
conversation like we've got to tell
actively like at some point we've got to
tell them that we've got a zombie game
in the middle of this very serious World
War two game and so we had to invite you
to the exact Ajoke from Activision one
at a time so don't worry about this
don't worry everything's good but just
play this it goes what you think sure oh
wow and we realized that what it's fun
was one of the executives are sending
his email back saying I made it around
twelve irate smile yeah oh that was that
was the point we're like okay we can put
it in but the part of the deal was we
weren't going to advertise or talk about
in any way and interestingly enough I
think that is a really strong reason for
why it became successful is because we
didn't put the Activision machine
we we just let the community find it
then the community actually took it and
made it around so that's pretty cool a
decision to kind of not really formally
recognize it it was probably one of the
best decisions we ever made because it's
a it allowed the community own it as
their own tech and then spawned like the
mystery right of like doing this your
eggs and just like that community's
already like invested well they were
yeah I mean when that word first came
out it had very simple stuff in there
but the community were actually writing
the law and was writing a story because
we had no story pretty much when we did
the first one and but they wrote the
story and so that's that's a spirit
we've taken all the way through to today
which is we'll look at kind of feedback
a lot of people saying and then make
decisions about the narrative and where
we're going based on what the community
is feeling now you got the careful but
you don't want the tail wagging the dog
right but you want to listen to it and
then make decisions that hopefully give
people options and places to go but aunt
isn't too constituted hi great I lived
was it that at first play or demo you
had the activision was it that first map
yeah next yeah yeah yeah
and that was just a section of one of
the campaign right that's right remember
yeah yeah that was on the last level
wasn't it or like I kind of trying to
remember it a knack it I think it was
oza that is in the back top I remember
that like crashed around there yeah yeah
yeah it's one of the airfield see about
that okay
and this is something that happened very
often in developing take or pieces from
project working on and then change those
other things that's how you can approach
that quite quickly I see our friend
mystery box aloft there yeah
I know I get hey there
you guys building finally company by the
job well I got two weapons I use in
black ops 3 players okay
oh god I'm on fire though so you know
that's cool you mean that literally or
figuratively yeah well I was and then I
died it was both I was on fire
it's okay double war fine everything
yeah prone there pronin will hunt for
water I see you guys oh yeah you're
gonna wonder if you can help if you can
maybe help and there's a monkey chasing
hi oh cool I'm out of ammo so well this
is not gonna go well but I'm doing
anyway so uh okay so you got me no see
you next round
hey how we're good we're chillin army
right
okay I've been okay finally have a look
great there's their teleporter as well
what's trending with this
oh I don't know is this um this is not
that a teleporter Ridgid something like
it
Ronde out you bet that's your bad daddy
I need help okay guys a galvanizing
routine right a little bit
I just got flanked real bad while I
order no water thick thick I'm down I'm
getting I'm moving to where I'm just
gonna go towards you guys watch out
though I think I think I'm gonna go go
go
I got this I just wanna be okay oh oh
no yeah
Wow
you know the Browns are going down as
we're going on inside of 12 yeah yeah
that is a tricky one I don't how we do
on time at that um uh well we started
Lemoine so we have we have time for one
more thing let's see one more
okay next what we got gave me an easier
easy one an easier man that was uh let's
do origins then let's do an easy was it
just an end on a high note I don't like
to swear on this but yeah you might not
be yeah we can guide you could either
and the next book
Oh my dad let's go Shh kids like alright
dad to say it maybe play later just
before camera crap um okay this is I
like run I want to tell you this is
completely worth it watching you guys
play that's it like Rob I usually focus
on like one yeah okay and so this is
just a little painting my mr. Alex Ross
it better it seems so calm
ah yeah heart they seem like very
majestic like you know exactly what's
going on which is the opposite of me
something's how we would like you to
think if you would like to play this
game we were giving out coats if you
would like to show me how it's done
you can die because you can follow
gamespot on twitter and retweet for a
chance to win winners we take the peanut
a what's after the giant robot oh my god
robot one one tribe conversion there's
world war two right yeah
oh I thought I have a Luger I was
thinking we're gonna Luger Zhanna one
the muslin I got oh this is no risk I
like to flip them off
well we its the accuracy I mean I'm not
trying to say this should be
historically accurate what is it about
their jaws falling apart if I just drop
out camera shot now huh
okay
became like see us living did
yes resolved zombie robot that's
interesting combo hmm a robot that was
rebooted came back to life what does all
be robot with me which one downstairs I
have so what about like um voiceover or
dubbing all that is the same in each one
of these yeah it's uh it's the same guys
can increase the resolution of the the
audio files and sell so you should
rather be crisper and clearer but yeah
all the same guys awesome I don't want
to be everybody yeah it was one of the
kind of wonderful things about even
though we kind of rebooted in terms of
storyline with let's say origins going
into we have following the premise crew
it's the same actors so we just been
able to write it differently and asked
them to perform it's slightly different
but the same guys doing it that's great
yeah
do those guys do a lot of voiceover work
oh yeah oh yeah although you know Fred
Texas or no Lenore no oh whoa I didn't
know that okay yeah all the others guys
are mm-hmm I'm absolutely right to work
with the clock I can only put in like
10% of the stuff that she was the board
actually into the game their admins are
just too funny
there's a mystery box there no I'm
following you
I'm adult and diving was always fun
oh yeah yeah now we can't just slide
down
yeah well that oh oh how are we hanging
there
oh maybe not
zombies no faces I I just like charged
in night when I should not have all
right here we go oh thanks breath that's
a no problem morphine logic do the trick
yeah
is there in our the round entry boxes in
this one or is it okay okay oh my god
whoa alright well
Rios is quite the conflict right now
there's a lot going on I love it
who would have thought that willow one
was so mechanized
the guy is it it somewhere
yes oh I can oh that's awesome to
teleport your situation I know this is
terrible bottleneck we've created
Aurora's honey
this one seems like a tough map to like
uh develop oh my god oh yeah okay a
memorable like um they say yeah half for
like route
well they do they do they do have places
online where this hook up perfect flow
right I can use everything correctly in
the right amount time there was actually
a formula me
what the die I don't wanna die no I said
I want to die how did I do I feel so
worse to dig who just got me up no I am
Jake you're a zombie what is going on
here
oh boy oh geez okay let's all just
huddle up it's your gobble gum yeah uh I
know I definitely forgot well you know
hey party Jake say Georgie take pick me
[Applause]
yeah
Wow Oh God where is the mystery box
indeed yeah where that doesn't that's
not that little sky oh I see okay I'm
just gonna run past that bomb
[Laughter]
I don't I don't have anything good
all right behind us now Shh I'm coming
oh oh god I think they're coming for you
yep nope yep
this is so so bad oh my god I just ran
into a dead end and in the trenches
we're all in this together yeah so close
hey guys I'm here about your first deaf
estate 9jp Oh check it it take a little
breather yeah yeah round seven all right
hey Flynn broke guys liberal ah
the closer I feel like I'm getting
towards the box I'm I'm never gonna make
it
he's a way to open the gateway Oh swing
caboose he said you have to follow the
steps
some on foot
sound concern god damn it
where did you come from where's the
power
okay what a way to go out
Jake revived me and I didn't even notice
Jay I'm sorry you can't I Wasi that was
progressively less rounds each time
let's go faster well alright um you know
fewer rounds but more fun yeah so more
camaraderie that's what really matters
the the team is restaurant the real
victory was the friends we made along
the way so we're not worth quarters all
right well I thank you guys for playing
with us um Thank You Jake for carrying
um and thank you all for watching again
that was call of duty black ops 3
zombies Chronicles 8 remastered classic
zombies maps um we will see you next
time
you